what
is up with us white people
i've been thinking about that a lot the
last few years and i know i have company
look i get it people of color have been
asking that question for centuries
but i think a growing number of white
folks are too
given what's been going on out there
in our country and notice i said what's
up with
us white people because right now i'm
not talking about
those white people the ones with the
swastikas and the hoods and the tiki
torches
they are a problem and a threat
they perpetrate most of the terrorism in
our country as you all
in charlottesville know better than most
but i'm talking about something bigger
more pervasive
i'm talking about all of us white folks
writ large
and maybe especially people sort of like
me
self-described progressive don't want to
be racist
good white people
any good white people in the room i was
raised
to be that sort of person i was a little
kid in the 60s and 70s
and to give you some sense of my parents
actual public opinion polls at the time
showed that only a small minority about
20 percent of white americans
approved and supported martin luther
king and his work with the civil rights
movement
while dr king was still alive
i'm proud to say my parents were in that
group
race got talked about in our house
and when the shows about that dealt with
race would come on the television they
would sit us kids down
made sure we watched the sydney poitiers
movies
roots the message was loud and clear and
i got it
racism is wrong racists are bad people
at the same time we lived in a very
white place
in minnesota and i'll just speak for
myself i think that allowed me to
believe that those white racists on the
tv screen were being beamed in from some
other place
it wasn't about us really i did not
feel implicated
now i would say i'm still in recovery
from that early impression
i got into journalism in part because i
cared about
things like equality justice
for a long time racism was just such a
puzzle to me
why is it still with us when it's so
clearly wrong
why such a persistent force
maybe i was puzzled because i wasn't yet
looking in the right place or asking the
right questions
have you noticed that when p people in
our
mostly white media
report on what they consider to be
racial issues what we consider to be
racial issues
what that usually means is that we're
pointing our cameras and our microphones
and our gaze
at people of color asking questions like
how are black folks or native americans
latino or asian americans
how are they doing in a given community
or with respect to some issue
the economy education
i've done my share of that kind of
journalism over many years
but then george zimmerman killed trayvon
martin
followed by this unending string of
high-profile
police shootings of unarmed black people
the rise of the black lives matter
movement
dylann roof and the charleston massacre
oscar's so white all the
uh incidents from the day-to-day of
american life these overtly racist
incidents that we now get to see because
they're captured on
smartphones and sent across the internet
and beneath those visible events the
stubborn data
the studies showing systemic racism in
every institution we have
housing segregation job discrimination
the deeply racialized inequities in our
schools and criminal justice system
and what really did it for me and i know
i'm not alone in this either
the rise of donald trump and the
discovery that
a solid majority of white americans
would embrace or at least accept
such a raw bitter kind of white identity
politics
this was all disturbing to me as a human
being
as a journalist i found myself turning
the lens
around thinking
wow white folks are the story whiteness
is a story and also thinking
can i do that what would a podcast
series about whiteness sound like
and oh by the way this could get
uncomfortable
i had seen almost no journalism that
looked deeply at whiteness
but of course people of color and
especially black intellectuals
have made sharp critiques of white
supremacist culture for centuries
and i knew that in the last two or three
decades scholars had done
interesting work looking at race through
the frame
of whiteness what it is how we got it
how it works in the world
i started reading and i reached out to
some leading experts on
race and the history of race
one of the first questions i asked was
where did this idea of being a white
person come from in the first place
science is clear we are one human race
we're all related all descended from a
common ancestor in africa
some people walked out of africa into
colder darker places and
lost a lot of their melanin some of us
more than others
but genetically we are all 99.9
the same there's more genetic diversity
within
what we call racial groups than there is
between racial groups there is no gene
for whiteness or blackness or asian-ness
or what have you
so how did this happen how did we get
this thing
how did racism start
i think if you had asked me to speculate
on that
in my ignorance some years ago i
probably would have said
well i guess somewhere back in
deep history people encountered one
another
and they found each other strange your
skin is a different color your hair is
different
you dress funny i guess i'll just go
ahead and jump to the conclusion that
since you're different
that you're somehow less than me and
maybe that makes it okay for me to
mistreat you
right is that something like what we
imagine or assume
and under that kind of scenario it's
sort of it's all a big tragic
misunderstanding
but it seems that's wrong
first of all race is a recent invention
it's just a few hundred years old
before that yes people divided
themselves
by religion tribal group language
things like that but for most of human
history people had no notion of race
in ancient greece for example and i
learned this from the historian
nell irvin painter the greeks
thought they were better than the other
people they knew about
but not because of some idea that they
were innately superior
they just thought they'd developed the
most advanced culture
so they looked around at you know the
ethiopians
but also the persians and the celts they
said they're all kind of barbaric
compared to us
culturally they're just not greek right
and yes in the ancient world there was
lots of slavery
but people enslaved people who didn't
look like them and they often enslaved
people who did
did you know that the english word slave
is derived from the word
slav because slavic people
were enslaved by all kinds of folks
including western europeans
for centuries right slavery wasn't about
race either because no one had thought
up race yet
so who did i put that question to
another leading
uh historian ibrahim kendy i didn't
expect he would
answer the question in the form of one
person's name and a date as if we were
talking about the light bulb
but he did
he said in in his exhaustive research he
found what he
believed to be the first articulation of
racist ideas
and he named the culprit this guy should
be more famous or infamous
his name is gomez de zerara
portuguese man wrote a book in the 1450s
in which he did something that no one
had ever done before according to dr
candy he lumped together all the people
of
africa vast diverse continent
and he described them as a distinct
group
inferior and beastly
never mind that in that pre-colonial
time some of the most
sophisticated cultures in the world were
in africa
why would this guy make this claim
turns out it helps to follow the money
first of all zarara was hired to write
that book by the portuguese king
and just a few years before slave
traders
here we go slave traders tied to the
portuguese crown
had effectively pioneered the atlantic
slave trade
they were the first europeans to sail
directly to sub-saharan africa
to kidnap and enslave african people
so it was suddenly really helpful to
have a story about the inferiority
of african people to justify this new
trade
to other people to the church to
themselves
and with the stroke of a pen zarara
invented both blackness and whiteness
because he basically
created the notion of blackness through
this description of
africans and as dr kennedy says
blackness has no meaning without
whiteness
other european countries followed the
portuguese lead
in looking to africa for human property
and free labor
and in adopting this fiction about the
inferiority of african people
i found this clarifying
racism didn't start with a
misunderstanding it started with a lie
meanwhile over here in colonial america
the people now calling themselves white
got busy taking these racist ideas and
turning them into law laws that
stripped all human rights from the
people they were calling black
and locking them into our particularly
vicious brand of chattel slavery
and laws that gave even the poorest
white people
benefits not big benefits in
material terms but the right to not be
enslaved for life
the right to not have your loved ones
torn from your arms and sold
and sometimes real goodies the handouts
of free land
to white places like virginia to white
people only
started long before the american
revolution
and continued long after now i can
imagine
there would be people listening to me if
they're still listening
who would might be thinking africa come
on this is all ancient history
why does this matter things have changed
can't we just get over it and move on
right but i would argue
for me certainly learning this history
has brought a real shift in the way that
i understand racism today
to review two quick takeaways from what
i've said so far
one race is not a thing biologically
it's a story some people decided to tell
and two people told that story to
justify the brutal exploitation of other
human beings
for profit i didn't learn those two
facts in school i suspect
most of us didn't if you did you had a
special teacher
right but once they sink in
for one thing it becomes clear that
racism is not
mainly a problem of attitudes of
individual bigotry
now it's a tool it's a tool to divide us
and to prop up systems economic
political and social
systems that advantage some people and
disadvantage
others and it's a tool to convince a lot
of white folks who may or may not be
getting
a great deal out of our highly
stratified society
to support the status quo could be worse
at least i'm white
once i grasped the origins of racism i
stopped being mystified by the fact that
it's still with us
i guess you know looking back i i
thought about racism as being sort of
like the flat earth
just bad outdated thinking that would
fade away on its own before long
but now this tool of whiteness is still
doing the job it was invented to do
powerful people go to work every day
leveraging and reinforcing
this old weapon in the halls of power
in some broadcast studios we could
mention
and we don't need to fuss over whether
these people believe what they're saying
whether they're really racist
that's not what it's about it's about
pocketbooks
and power
finally i think the biggest lesson of
all
and let me talk in particular to the
white folks for a minute
once we understand that people who look
like us
invented the very notion of race
in order to advantage themselves and us
isn't it easier to see that it's our
problem to solve
it's a white people problem i'm
embarrassed
to say that for a long time i thought of
racism as being
mainly a struggle for people of color to
fight
sort of like the people on the tv screen
when i was a kid
or as if i were on the sidelines at a
sports contest
on one side people of color on the other
those real racists
the southern sheriff the people in hoods
and i was sincerely rooting for people
of color to win the struggle
but now there are no sidelines
we're all in it we are implicated
and if i'm not joining the struggle to
dismantle a system that advantages
me i am complicit
this isn't about shame or guilt white
guilt doesn't get anything done and
honestly
i don't feel a lot of guilt history
isn't my fault
or yours what i do feel
is a stronger sense of responsibility
to do something
all this has altered the way that i
think about and approach my work
as a documentary storyteller and as a
teacher
but beyond that besides that what does
it mean what does it mean for any of us
does it mean that we support leaders who
want to push ahead with a conversation
about reparations
in our communities are we finding people
who are
working to transform unjust institutions
and supporting that work
at my job am i the white person who
shows up grudgingly for the diversity
and equity meeting
or am i trying to figure out how to be a
real accomplice to my colleagues of
color
seems to me wherever we show up
we need to show up with humility and
vulnerability
and a willingness to put down this power
that we did not
earn
i believe we also stand to benefit if we
could create
a society that's not built on the
exploitation or oppression of anyone
but in the end we should do this
we should show up figure out how to take
action
because it's right
thank you